multiple senators are now calling for
stop to the confirmation of Trump
Supreme Court nominee Neil Gorsuch until
the FBI investigation really multiple
different investigations actually are
completed into the Trump Russia
collusion scandal Chuck Schumer and
Elizabeth Warren are two of these
senators this makes perfect sense to me
Republicans didn't want obama selecting
a replacement for Antonin Scalia because
he was in his last year of his
presidency made absolutely no sense
Donald Trump is under multiple of is the
subject of multiple investigations
including by the FBI for colluding with
a foreign power to take control of the
White House which do you think justifies
taking it slow with a lifetime
confirmation to the country's top court
Obama being in his last year as
president or the president being under
FBI investigation for colluding with a
foreign nation one that is not
particularly friendly to the US and
consider something else with multiple
investigations into Donald Trump's
potential collusion with a foreign power
might this not be Donald Trump's last
year in office which would make it the
exact same argument as that which was
used by Republicans against President
Obama now that the standard has been set
by Republicans with Merrick garland last
year I assume any big change which could
affect electability would count as a
reason not to confirm a Supreme Court
nominee after all don't the voters need
to have a say I commend both Chuck
Schumer and Elizabeth Warren for this
Elizabeth Warren sending a tweet out
yesterday where she said the FBI
director testified Donald Trump's
campaign is under investigation for
collusion with Russia lifetime court
appointments can wait Senator Chuck
Schumer saying quote you can bet if the
shoe were on the other foot and a
Democratic president was under
investigation by the FBI the Republicans
would be howling at the moon about
filling a Supreme Court seat in such
circumstances will this gain any
traction not likely unless something
huge breaks from the investigation
into Trump's Russia connections
Republicans planning a boat on this next
month agree with me Pat that this is a
good strategy i think that democrats are
absolutely right to oppose this
nomination I'm not sure I agree with
this tactic realize I think you're
fighting a losing battle here of course
as of now you need 60 votes to confirm a
Supreme Court justice that's what's
precedent is yeah but Mitch McConnell
could just use the nuclear option and
then you only need a simple majority 51
so if Democrats don't really have an
endgame they're just going to be
fighting a losing battle from the
beginning wouldn't forcing Mitch
McConnell to need the nuclear option be
a win in and of itself insofar as that
is something which then you can
criticize Republicans for I mean I don't
pick so because I don't think that's
something that registers with most of
the American public and the other point
i have here too is that you know Ward's
which isn't so connected to this Russia
scandal at all and the thing is even if
Donald Trump was impeached who would be
his replacement Mike Pence or if pence
was also impeached Paul Ryan yeah but it
would still be a preservative just it
would still be a scandal to lose your
Supreme Court nominee no matter who it
is that would then be picking the next
one I think that the the the argument is
if the context under which the president
is selecting someone to be on the court
matters and Republicans claimed that it
mattered under Obama being his last year
in office then the context under which a
Donald Trump's choice is being confirmed
matters and the context is Trump is
being investigated by the FBI and I
think Democrats definitely should have
pushed harder against Republicans at
that time when they refuse to even hear
anything from merrick garland but the
thing is at this point they never had
the Senate it's not like they were ever
going to get to a point where they could
get their nomination confirmed not then
and not now I really don't know that
because it's unlikely to ultimately work
it's an it's a bad idea I believe that
if Republicans can hold up Antonin
Scalia seat for a year for no good
reason Democrats should absolutely be
able to hold it up for a few more months
at minimum but this isn't for some
made-up reason the president who
selected this dude is being investigated
by not only the FBI but also by the
house Intel committee etc etc for
possibly colluding with an unfriendly
foreign nation to take power of the
white
house but there are actually many other
reasons to hold up this nomination as
well when the republican party last year
held up Merritt Garland's nomination by
President Obama they destroyed the
nomination process as we knew it and the
entire system has lost credibility and i
think that there's a better case to be
made for democrats Pat to hold up this
nomination before anything goes forward
there should be a decision that puts
into writing what the policy is so
Democrats should say we are not moving
forward on this until one of two things
happens number one we make it part of
some established process that presidents
can't nominate in their last year of a
term okay put it in writing if that's
the unwritten policy make it a written
policy unlikely to happen you agree
right pad I mean it's unlikely that
we'll see that not under a Republican
control mode number two if that's not
going to happen then Merrick garland
should be given confirmation hearings
which obviously is also not going to
happen the Republican party doesn't care
about rules they certainly don't care
about fairness there are multiple
reasons for Democrats to vote no in in
committee and in the Senate for this
nomination I support Elizabeth Warren
and Chuck Schumer on this and I hope
that they will convince all Democrats to
do the same thing we will see we will
see